how well do Americans know their future
princess i'm lauren zima and we are
spilling the royalty on Hollywood
Boulevard Hollywood Americans come here
from all over to see the city of stars I
came to find out if the average American
knows much about our rising royal star
that's Prince Harry's future wife Megan
Markel but first I had to get someone to
talk to me
you guys want to interview now really
come on no okay they don't speak English
well it's time for a quick interview
the rejection is real today guys sir an
interview on the royal family on America
red white and blue they're across the
pond but we're all in the same heart
anyone in a car want to do an interview
the wind is blowing away as are my hopes
of getting the American people spots on
the Royal Wedding Hollywood Boulevard
also known as rejection Street but Harry
didn't feel like this with Megan she was
into him right away why wouldn't she be
luckily just like the times are changing
in the royal family the tide turned for
us people started stopping by you know
who this is um no idea well I'm with
sparkle yes Megan farkles the future of
the world do you know who this is
looks like stacey dash maybe he really
was tired I know that she used to be on
that show what with the show Glee was a
Glee
[Music]
was it orange is the new black
isn't that the princess fiance yes very
good do you know where she's from I know
she was on a show she's marrying Prince
Harry and she's on suits I know that
this must be incredibly difficult and
she can't do the show anymore because of
the Queen well seems like everybody
needs to get more acquainted with Megan
Markel and maybe with the royal family
all together - can you name two other
members of the British royal family
Princess Kate and her husband who is
enough isn't it the only other son of
the icon Princess Diana what is his name
have you ever been to the store Blanc
Sonoma Blanc sherry here Perry Sonoma
you get all your pots and pans at Harry
Sonoma what's on your head hair your
prince hair Prince hair it's Prince hair
okay you've nailed it good can you name
two other members of the royal family
you know there's Queen Elizabeth rest in
peace and he is still alive
oh okay cook it Queen Elizabeth I love
her what do you think about the Prince
marrying an American we're gonna have an
American in the royal family what Prince
does same one that's married to Kate
things were looking grim luckily if
there's one thing that can bring us hope
it's a wise woman do you know who this
is
yes million Markel Jimmy thank you
you're one of the few people today who
has their information rights can you
well older and wiser can you tell me one
other thing you know about Meghan
Markell any fact about her she used to
be an actress yes Jenny wonderful oh
we're gonna do a selfie okay now your
family
Prince William Megan Marco or Kate
Middleton Megan Marco how come
I like Deal or No Deal what a throwback
answer I love you remembering her from
that what does the mega need to do to
prove herself in the royal family um
honestly just keep doing her I feel like
she's doing a great job she's breaking a
lot of the like social norms of the
royal family which is good she is the
first app you know somewhat
african-american to be in the royal
family and we love that yeah we love it
times they are a-changin they're
changing thank God thank God Yeah right
he's got yet so we found a few diamonds
in the rough but still so much to learn
there's only one conclusion I've come to
I have got to mind the gap I have got to
cross the pond everybody I have an
announcement I will be heading to the
British royal wedding in May yes I
Lauren Zima I'm going to
some unite our two countries once again
and until then we will be here every
Friday on spilling the royalty to bring
you all the latest Royal news everything
you need to know about this fabulous
royal wedding
thanks so much guys i'm lauren zima
cheerio
[Music]
okay got rejected by spider-man so by
doorman he doesn't want to talk about
the princess fine spider-man not exactly
the American Hero we thought he was
spider-man